hello everyone welcome to a video on
code tech and tutorials my name is matt
and today we're going to be looking at
davinci resolve
17. davinci resolve is
video editing software and effect
software somewhat talented as the
i don't know the long side with adobe
premiere it's like
about as good as adobe premiere i guess
you would say
however i have more experience with
davinci resolve not a whole lot with
adobe premiere because i tend to use
free stuff if i can
and davinci resolve does have a free
version whereas
adobe premiere does not
so i want to talk a little bit about my
experience and go through
the very basics of how you actually use
this if
you're a complete beginner and don't
have any idea what you're doing so this
will be a tutorial
on how to edit video with resolve
from the standpoint of a complete
beginner so if you already know resolve
and are pretty good at it this is
probably going to be a lot of
information you already know
if you have no idea what it is then cool
here we go now you can see they have a
website here
and they have all kinds of things like
training and
studio and stuff
we're not really going to worry about
anything other than
recording with our own computer now this
is semi
professional software so you can do very
high quality edits
with resolve
and that's what makes it so great that's
what makes it better than things like
like blender as a video editor you know
i've done a lot of tutorials on that
but this is in my opinion a good
next step but there are a few
requirements
now with all these effects and the
powerhouse that davinci resolve seems to
be
it does require quite a bit of
processing power
so it's it's good to know that that's a
thing
and by a lot i do mean mostly mostly
your gpu of course your cpu
your ram you always need a lot of that
kind of stuff for video editing
but i've noticed when i edit with
resolve if i have a
pretty long video with a lot of effects
on my laptop
which doesn't have a whole lot of gpu
memory i'll often get this message that
says
out of gpu memory so just know that this
relies pretty heavily on
a good graphics card from what i
understand and if you don't have one
you're going to have a rough time
getting this program going
so it does require a bit of a newer
computer with it
with decent specs including the video
card so that's one of the things about
this i don't know if adobe's like that
i've never used adobe
but here is the download and
i'm not gonna go through the download
but i'll explain it
super quick in case people get stuck
when you download this
it downloads as a compressed file
so you have to uncompress that file and
then run the installer
and that's it if you're stuck on that
that's a that's really a different thing
than using resolve but it shouldn't be
too hard
so let's get into it
oh my goodness look at all this stuff
and there's tons of accessories in
things you can hook up consoles you can
hook up to do additional
cool editing i'm just going to be using
a regular keyboard and mouse
but there's lots of these editing
keyboards and
stuff that's you know one day maybe i'll
get to
but right now i'm just using davinci
resolve 17 free
so if you want to follow along that's
what it's going to be
so once you have davinci resolve
installed you'll have an icon probably
on your desktop
or wherever you installed it or maybe
it's in your start menu
that's kind of up to you basically you
want to get installed and be able to
launch
resolve which will look like this
there's also a project
server i have never really used this so
i'm going to kind of ignore that one
we're just going to look at the actual
program so all you do is open it
it is going to take a bit of time as it
loads up looks for your control surfaces
checks everything that's hooked up to
your computer
and all that stuff so it's pretty normal
for this to take a bit as it loads up
all its resources
and once once it finishes launches oh my
god what did i just say
once it finishes launching you'll see
this server thing
with databases and you see it says
davinci resolve 16 here i think i'm
actually using 16
on this computer so
uh when i get 17 installed it's
basically the same
i just you know i said i was doing a
tutorial on 17.
let me go actually get 17. be right back
and real quick just to note 17 is in
beta
16 is the official release right now so
if you want the most stable version
you should probably use 16 and they're
pretty close
but we're going to be talking about 17
if you're using 16 you'll probably be
able to follow along things which might
be in different spaces
and you're probably also going to have a
more stable experience if you're on 16
but i haven't really noticed any issues
with 17
so let me go get 17.
okay so back on their web page
just going to go ahead and grab 17. now
you see there's just plain old resolve
17
free that's the one we're going to be
using studio
fine costs money and if you're
professional doing
you know big stuff you probably want the
studio version but if you're just
playing around and testing things out
then 17 should be fine and here we go
here's the downloads
and you can see it works for mac windows
and linux which is awesome okay i'm
going to go ahead and get the windows
davinci resolve 17 beta and i guess i
can walk through this now
i think i'm already registered i'm going
to skip over
this
okay got all that filled out with just
some basic information
it doesn't make you make an account or
anything it just asks who you are
basically and i don't know if there's a
way around that exactly
but i feel like i filled it out more
than once and any time you actually
click update from within the program you
don't have to fill that out again so
that's a little weird but yeah as you
can see it's downloading
over here in the bottom left corner and
we'll let that finish and i'll come back
to you guys
okay so it did finish downloading and i
just popped it open
i'm using this program called pzip
to extract files you might use winrar or
just the windows default one or
something
whatever is fine and you can just double
click it from here and it will auto
extract to a temp area
and start the install
which i don't necessarily recommend what
i usually do instead is i usually just
grab this file and save it to some place
on my hard drive
so i'm just going to hit extract go to
uh all right this is fine
e downloads that's one of my big
physical drives
so i'm gonna save this uh installer over
there
and all this does is extract it this
isn't the install
right here so however you extract it
it's fine
basically we just want to get it out of
this compressed file
you don't know what compressed style
files are for and their purpose
i just it's kind of off topic
but very quickly i will say it's so
davinci doesn't have to
use so many resources from
all these people downloading it because
they can make the file a little smaller
to download and then you can manually
unzip it and
take it from there all right so let me
go to where i saved that
and it looks like it's just right over
here on the e drive downloads there's
going to be a whole bunch of junk in
here we're just looking for the davinci
resolve there it is so that's what we're
going to double click
and apparently it's not showing the icon
but it doesn't matter we're just going
to double click it
and we can close this window
and it's going to extract yet again
this is like double compressed i guess
and it's going to go through the
installation process now you may have
already done this
feel free to skip forward i'll try to
put time stamps all over this video so
you can get to parts that are relevant
for you
but i just want to cover all the bases
for
very new people and here we are you see
you get the blackmagic role player
davinci control panels and davinci
resolve
now i think the main thing you need here
is davinci resolve but if you have space
you might as well install everything
and let it do its thing this is going to
take a while there's no doubt about that
so yeah i'll be back
all right it's looking pretty well and
good i got things popping up asking me
questions so i'm just going to accept
the terms of course
and the installation area
i'm not sure if i want it here this is
generally the default area just to
program files but if you want it on
another drive
you can do that i'm going gonna yeah i'm
just gonna keep it
where it was program files blackmagic
design
davinci resolve that should be okay for
me
and i think this is gonna be it there's
not really a whole lot to this
once it's done we should get a new icon
over here i don't know if it's going to
replace 16 or not i haven't actually had
them both installed on a computer before
version 16 and 17 beta so we'll find out
it's chugging away here looks like it's
finalizing
and it did go ahead and remove all my 16
shortcuts so i think it's replacing 16.
so it might be the case that you can
only have one installed at a time or if
you choose the same
install location as 16 it will overwrite
it
good to know there's a lot of times
people will want both versions they'll
want you know 16
for their stable guaranteed functioning
stuff because it's a release and then
they'll want 17 to play around
and test the new features
but i'm not super worried about that as
i'm not a professional video editor or
anything like that
i just want 17 functional i've used it
before i know how to render stuff
i know how to generally get videos done
and that's what i'm going to show you
okay so it did finish here and it gave
us a slightly different icon it's a
little more squarish
then the old one and we're just going to
hit finish here let it do its thing
and boom we should be able to now just
open davinci
resolve so let's go ahead and here we go
it's going to take a minute to load up
again
so while this is loading up i can show
you
just a few things about videos so
video formats matter davinci resolve
doesn't accept
all types and these mkv files that you
see here
which are the default when
you're recording with obs or something
it seems to default default to these mkv
files now i think you can change this in
obs to like mp4s
which you might want to do if you're
going to be using this a lot
because you'll find that you can't just
drag in these mkb files
so that's something that's sort of
interesting and a bit of a monkey wrench
but it's not that big of a deal because
what you can do is if you have
incompatible files or files of different
frame rates and stuff and i've said this
a bunch in my video tutorials about
blender
as you can use a program called
handbrake
to turn all your files into a common
frame rate
and a common file type and i think by
default if you just drop a file in here
and
and convert it it centers it into like a
1080
uh okay we gotta pop up here it turns
into a 1080
uh mp4 so if your videos
if you find that you can't import them
or the resolve doesn't like them
just uh convert them with handbrake
first and then go back to resolve
and use those so just so you know
if you got those incompatible weird
files and you're getting all kinds of
weird errors
you need to sync them all that's the
same type or
i say sync them all but convert them all
with handbrake
to a type you can actually use so like a
lot of raw formats from cameras you'll
need to do this
too and like i mentioned earlier i'm not
a professional video editor
i'm kind of approaching this from like a
computer science
programmer perspective and so i
generally can figure out the technical
stuff
but i'm i'm no artistry of
mastery on video editing just so you're
aware
i'm not sure if that was proper sentence
even okay so i did finish this it gets
a message about upgrading your existing
database i'm going to go ahead and do
this i think it's the right choice
because i was using 16 and i think it
needs to
do something new and there we go okay so
it does have all my stuff
from davinci 16 it did import it so as
you can see i have some saved projects
here
so when you first open it and it
finishes loading you generally get
this thing and you can see you can
change the size of those no big deal
this is just your projects we're just
going to do a new project
so i'm going to go down here click new
project
we're going to give it a name i'll just
give it a youtube demo one
because this is my first video on
resolve
and there we go it pops open and you get
this whole
interface now i'm going to take a few
minutes and walk through this interface
talk a little bit about it
now down at the bottom this is one of
the most important things to kind of
get a hang on a hang up i guess um
this is the section or like your editing
workflow
so most of the time when you're editing
a video you're going to be sitting on
cut and edit for me personally i sit
and edit for a really long time after i
get my videos imported but to get them
imported
at first you want to go over to this
first tab media
and it gives you this screen and you can
navigate through your hard drives
and bring in files
so let me figure out something to bring
in and i'll show you some more
okay so we're going to look for a video
now like i was saying you can use these
to go find your video or you can just
drag in from your file explorer but you
do need to be in this media section
and you either drag it i think you drag
it right here so i'm going to go
to my mask drive here so i have one to
just save lots of stuff
and i have an area called handbrake
where i generally
invert things and save the initial
conversion here and then drag them out
from here
just my style doing things you can do it
your own way however you want but the
point is
everything i have in my recording is an
mkv so i can't just
demo any of these easily because if i
drag them in it's just gonna
it's just gonna nope it's gonna be like
nope so i've got some things
i previously converted to an mp4
and that's what i'm going to use as the
samples just take a look at this
it's an m4v i mean but close enough
so this type of file should work so
we're just going to drag it
here and it asks if we want to change
the project
frame rate to match what we're dragging
in and you want to go ahead and do this
usually
and there we go now this particular clip
isn't anything to do with
my channel it's just i think a recorded
match of playing some mtg arena which is
just a video game of magic the gathering
yeah you may have heard of it it's
pretty fun i like magic
i played a lot um so that's the clip i
got here
so this is what i'm going to be using
for the sample now you can see it's in
here
there's little special features of
davinci like you can kind of scroll
through it right here just by moving
your mouse there's a lot of little cool
bonus features now once you have the
things in that you want you don't really
need to do a whole lot else here you
just kind of you know drag in the media
you like
from your your project files now a lot
of people like organize their files in
special ways they make a special folder
they put everything for the project in
it
i don't tend to do that because i'm just
like winging it like once i get the
video done and rendered i
never go back and open it again because
you know that's that's my style
but most professional editors will like
section off their projects drag all
these particular files into an organized
folder structure before
opening this project you know that's but
we're not going to worry about that
we're going to skip over all that so all
we do next
is we want to make a timeline because
just dragging the media in here
doesn't really do anything so if we go
like over to cut
we see our clips up here but there's no
timeline down here and same with edit no
timeline down here
so all you do is you take this file when
you're in this cut
and you just drag it down here and it'll
create a new timeline
as you can see it shows us a resource so
these timelines
use your resources and they're like a
new resource that's just the way it
eventually works
but now we have this whole area down
here for cutting
and right here we have a quick
view as you can see it goes to
an hour and 40 minutes that was a long
video wow
and this initial cut is
sort of made to just quickly scroll
through
and make cuts and and just like
get your initial uh you know you want to
cut the parts you don't want
and that sort of thing and you'll find
some tools to do that there's some
special tools here like
boring detector to see i think you can
set this but it basically
does a little scan sees if you've got
anything go on for longer than your time
that says uh
you know this this is boring you should
probably do some edits that's just like
a
helper thing you don't really need to do
that there's split clips
uh there's some of this stuff i haven't
used a ton of this but some of this is
is decent initial effects uh you'll have
to play around with it some
if i start diving into all of these
it'll take me forever
but generally what i do here is uh
well sometimes i just skip this entirely
but if i know for sure there's like
giant sections i want to cut out
i'll go in here and you can just like i
think you right click
you get the play header to where you
want you right click on it
and you can see there's a cut and
there's a split
keep left and a split keep right so this
is kind of tricky like if you go
like if i could do this i can undo so
it's not a big deal
oh is it doing it
hold on i think i got to cut first so if
i do a cut
and then i click here again oh that's a
select
okay select left select right so it just
has some basic tools and there's hotkeys
for these i don't know all the hotkeys
yet so i do a lot of clicking
but you know you can go look at them
there's probably somewhere up here where
you can view them all or you can
download like a little cheat sheet or
something
but they do vary depending on what
section you're in
so we got a cut there and let's say
we just want to get rid of it so what
you can do
is you can grab these edges once you
make a cut so let's make it like another
cut
right here i'm just doing sample cuts i
don't mean anything i'm going to cut
there
so now we have this section and say we
want to cut off a little bit of this we
just drag it
and it automatically pulls back the clip
after it so this cut section is kind of
designed
to make it super easy and if i want to
cut off say
from here to here i can drag on this
side and pull some of it and you can see
it's like playing
or you can hear it's like playing the
audio too so it tries to help you
with playing a little bit of the audio
it's pretty good at doing that sort of
thing so that's generally what you do
you go through this initially
you cut out all all the parts you don't
like you can use this at the bottom to
scroll in advance
click somewhere do some cuts
drag it in and out to kind of like make
it better for how you want
and you can you can kind of do this for
your first initial pass i think
that this is supposed to be for like
your first pass
oh and another weird thing actually i
said this wrong earlier i don't know
it's a weird thing but it said like
right here it says like one hour 29
minutes
i'm not sure why the one is in front it
should be zero
uh because this is like a 40 minute
video
not not a one hour and 40 but i don't
know why it always does that
so someone wants to explain that in the
comments that would help but that
always confuses me because i pop in my
video and i think it's an hour longer
than it is like i already said
but it's not i don't know why this says
hour and 40 minutes it's only 40 minutes
it's just a weird thing i guess they
start at one their arrays start at one
for da vinci
they didn't get the programming memo
where things start at zero but anyway
we're going to move on
that's basically all i want to show you
for this section uh other than these are
kind of cool
if you've got this semi-finalized like
you don't think you're going to do any
more edits over a cut
you can drag in one of these dissolve
things
let me see if i can get this oh there we
go we just click
i guess you just click it and it does it
near the nearest cut so it's trying to
help you
so you can kind of make some quick
fade cuts here too while you're in this
so say i do another cut here
maybe i pull off some of that then i
want it to do
some other thing like this smooth cut
you just click it
and it applies it over your latest cut i
think so you can kind of get your
initial
pass going here of just like you know
going through your video you probably
watch more closely
than i'm doing i'm not watching it
particularly that closely
uh because it's just uh you know kind of
a demo but here we go we can do this
sort of thing
that's just a cut that's dissolve that
smooth cut okay
so you can play around with these see
how you see how you like them there's
this close-up feature
uh i'll show you a couple more of them
these are all totally optional like we
have this little section here
and if i click the section and then
click close up
it automatically puts an effect well i
wanted to put this effect this
didn't put it where i expected so i put
it
after my cut for some reason i'm not
entirely sure how all these features yet
work yet some of them are
seem a little weird to me like for
example i just put this
close up so i don't know what it's going
to do exactly but let's take a look
it looks like it just auto zooms in on
that particular section
and then zooms back out and now you can
change it how you want if you move it
to there it does a little snap so you
can get it to snap there so
you can kind of put these initial little
things over it
uh of some just basic cuts
ripple overwrite a pen all right we're
gonna move on from cut
because once you get through your first
pass and you got your basic cuts uh
you know removed all your bad pieces
basically then you go to edit
and sometimes just to be perfectly
honest i completely skip this cut
section and go straight to edit
because you can do all the cut stuff
over here on edit as well plus a little
bit more
it's just uh it's just a little messier
of a looking interface there's more
tools more effects you can do
okay so we've got this looking half
decent now once you're in edit
you get the special feature of this zoom
bar here i love this thing
because you can minus it all the way and
see you know the length of
your entire thing or you can zoom way in
if you're doing some precise edits so
you'll you'll kind of flip around
between this as you go
like if you're doing some meticulous
little effect you want to zoom way in
and get a look at what you're doing now
what you're in this section
there are some new options you have
snapping snapping will basically snap
to this cursor here or snap to ends
so you can turn it off by pressing the n
hotkey i use this all the time
so if i turn it off do a cut now cutting
is a little different to here too you
can't just right click and cut anymore
you have to do that
you know you get different options here
in the edit so what you do
is you click this thing the blade mode
or press b
so you press b get it on the blade mode
and you just click somewhere
and it cuts so you can do this all over
the place very fast
and you can control z or undo if you
mess them up
so i'll just make a few here real quick
and as you can see the video up here is
updating as i scroll along
so you can kind of see what you're
working with super cool feature
alright so with snapping on
and i want to get off this blade cut so
let's go over to selection mode
which is a there's also trim mode and
dynamic mode i
pretty much stick with blade and
selection mode like 90 of the time
but you know professional might do
things different
so what you do you go to the selection
mode if you turn snapping on
it's going to like snap to your cursor
when you get close to it
so it's going to be hard to like see
it's not even snapping off it just kind
of sticks
if you don't want it to do that and it
also does the same thing to the next
uh area where it can uh
you know reduce your
dead space i guess you would call it and
this thing is also snapping
so if you don't want it to do that and
you have your own precise edits you can
turn that off
by just pressing n and it won't
snap to things anymore because sometimes
that snapping messes you up if you just
want to cut like
two frames and keep snapping to the edge
or something alright very good
so i'll show you a few other clips the
whole snapping
and cutting is like the bread and butter
of this section for me anyway
i'm usually doing all sorts of little
precise things here then i'll click this
clip and say hey
maybe i want to effect on just this clip
here
so once you have a clip selected you can
go over here
to your toolbox and if you don't see it
i believe you just got to click
this little thing here or one of these
you'll probably see it
but there's tabs up here and these tabs
up here affect this
left side so there's your media pool
if you want to drag more stuff in here
you can there's your effects
library and you have a toolbox open
effects audio effects
a bunch of stuff here generally i stick
with these
in video transitions you can drag these
over
cuts that are next to each other for
example if we drag these next to each
other
you can see since i don't have snapping
it's like automatically
kind of overlapping it and doing some
weird stuff so maybe i want snapping
here
so it snaps and doesn't do an overlap
i'm not sure what length selection is
i'd never use that
but uh we'll get into that maybe later
if this gets like a lot of
views and people want to see more i can
dig in and give some more advanced
tutorials but
we're just trying to stick with the
basics of like some cutting and some
basic effects
and then rendering it for youtube that's
that's all this is all right so maybe
that's something i should have said
right at the beginning maybe it did
this has been going on for almost 30
minutes so i'm kind of losing track a
little bit i'm just going to keep going
and we're going to get to
a resolution here so effects i was
talking about effects
you can drag these video transitions
onto any
seam like this so if i just grab for
example cross
to dissolve and drag it and put it right
here
now it's going to do a cross to dissolve
right at that transition so if i just
hit play here
yeah let's get a look at it
and as you can see you couldn't even
really tell there because
it crossed but there was no action if
there's like actually action or you're
going to a completely different scene
you will notice but if it's like the
same if you're dissolving
crossfading to the same thing you know
you can't even tell
but if i was going to like i don't know
maybe some b-roll or something you would
see the the crossfade
so there's a lot of different ones here
that are kind of cool uh
let me get rid of this so you can select
it and just press the delete key
but you can check out these other ones
like this one here dip to color resolve
you'll see just watch what happens here
you'll see it like uh fades in and out
i use that one a lot that was a fun one
um
let's see there's smooth cut let's see
what that one looks like so you can just
play around with all these by just
dragging them in and taking a look can't
even tell there because it's
this is this is a pretty bad example of
a cut here because there's just no
change you know i just kind of picked a
random area this whole video is like
this you know it's just kind of a slow
paced magic game so
but your mileage will vary depending on
what you're doing so that's video
transitions
you just drag them in over these cuts
and uh and go from there and there's
other special stuff
a bunch of special stuff down here now
what you'll see
as you try to use these eventually
you're gonna get something like
uh let's see let me see if i can get it
to happen
i don't know what happened there that
was like a weird rotate but some of
these you'll try to use them and it'll
say something like
you're using the free version you can't
use this effect and stuff like that
these all seem to work but once you get
into these open fx's
a lot of these seem like they're
locked behind a paywall that one in
particular isn't but
eventually if you're playing around with
all these eventually you're going to run
into something where it's like
nope you're not allowed to do that there
it is you have reached a limitation with
davinci
and you need to buy it for 2.99 so i'll
say not yet because we're doing free
version and as you see
it just puts this thing over your effect
you get the lens flare
but you also get this whole little ad
thing
so the free version doesn't allow you to
do everything without a little bit of
hindrance it does try to
encourage you to buy the real one anyway
i'm going to undo this effect
but just know that that's the thing not
all this stuff works unless you buy the
full version so the free is a little bit
limited but you do get all the core
stuff
you just don't get all the super fancy
stuff for free
okay so what else might we want to do we
could look at audio transitions i don't
use those too much i usually just
manually crossfade titles are pretty
useful you basically just get some
text of some sort and you can say
whatever you want
so your properties for whatever you've
selected over here on the top right
under inspector and click different
things here i'm going to keep it
inspector
there's mixer two we'll get to that a
little later i'm not going to talk about
the mixer yet
but i will before the end of this so
this inspector here
is uh whatever you've selected it's some
properties
and you'll see some tabs up here like
this one only has video option
there's no effects or audio transition
but if you click on a different one
you'll see it has different stuff like
this one has audio attached to it so you
can go to audio and do stuff with the
audio
there are effects you can do that etc
etc so this is kind of how you
adjust the properties of whatever you've
selected
we're going to adjust the properties of
this text a little bit and we'll just
give this like
mtg arena we'll just say that as
a text thing and now i'm going to just
back this up and maybe i want this title
at the very beginning for example
you can just drag it and move it and if
you're in here and you want to move
this thing you can hold middle click
but if you're on a laptop or something
with no middle click you can just drag
this
and i'm just going to zoom way out
and that's actually hard to do because i
can't grab it easily
i'm not doing this in a conventional way
i'm just like messing around you know
so i don't know if i should have created
this at the beginning rather than having
to drag it now
but i guess i can do it like this just
grab it there it goes
so now at the very beginning it'll say
mtg arena
it's not a very good looking thing
but you can uh you can do these up you
can do all kinds of stuff with your text
as you can see there's font sizes
spacing
positions anchors so you make it look
fancy as fancy as you want there's
a offset of drop shadow i like drop
shadow a lot
helps see what's going on change the
color of it you can just do all sorts of
stuff
there's no real limitations here and
there's also settings
some transform stuff
and you know that's the text there's a
bunch of different ones here there's
some special ones that work
there's some that are hidden behind
paywall
but there's generally a lot of little
text and titles you can drag around
another cool thing i'll just go ahead
and show you you can do this on many
video clips or anything
is uh when you hover over one of these
you see these little
things at the edge top left top right
these are the fade and fade out so you
can customize the fade and fade out by
dragging this
and it tells you the time you're working
with as well
like that's about a one second fade
about a one second fade here
so now you'll see if i hit play here
you'll see that text fade in
there it goes and there's my kid talking
all right and then it fades out
all right um so
you can do the same thing with video or
text you can use these little things if
you notice
on the edge of any particular split
you'll see that so you can do a little
custom fade in fade out if you want real
quick just by grabbing those and be like
whoop
so that's kind of cool thing all right
let's uh let's move on from those
there's a lot you can play around with
there
now we have some generators i don't tend
to use these too much i think some
people like to use these you know
as a fact like oh i messed up sound or
whatever
so you can drag these in and do stuff
with them and get that
you know they just have some of these
built in
so kind of cool thing to play around
with if you want then they got some
additional effects
uh i haven't used these a ton i think
most of these are pay walled anyway yeah
they are
okay and then you got open effects i
haven't used
them i'm getting some weird things so
yeah when you're not using the full
version
it yells at you a lot anytime you try to
do something it's just like nope okay
this is the audio so
i it doesn't let you do that on the
video now the audio one is this
green one here you can click on it
you can do stuff with it but it's like
locked
to the video now i'm not going to get
into much about
that basically what you do is you go
over here to audio
and you can adjust it how you want
like you know with this so if you got a
background music track
you can you can put that in there too
i'll show you that real quick
okay so here we go i've got a bunch of
music in my downloads just stuff i've
used in the past some random stuff
random effects all kinds of stuff
so what you do is you basically just
drag this in if you try to drag it in
like here it looks like it goes ahead
and imports it but you can go back to
media or cut and drag it in there
and generally what you want to do is you
want to drag it into its own
track because if you drag it right here
you see it overwrites the track from the
audio
so if you don't want it to overwrite
your audio you got to drag it below
or above maybe no it's got to be below
and start a new one
so then both will play now two different
audio
clips so what you want to do here
is you can click on one of these like
okay so this
right here is my music and i don't want
it to be full volume
right here because you know there's
talking you won't be able to hear me
talking for example i'll just hit play
real quick
[Music]
all right well that's that's another
it's way too loud and the other one's
way too quiet
so what you can do is you can adjust the
volume right here
but you don't necessarily have to do it
this way there's some options since we
have two different tracks
what we can do is we can go over to this
fairlight audio tab
and we'll get a new interface and we'll
see here
that we have our first audio track right
here left and right and our other one
that's our music
audio 2 a left and right so you can
start playing around with just the audio
here
and you've got these dials over here on
the bottom right
uh there's a lot of stuff you can do
here i'm gonna keep it real simple so
basically if you want your music to be
real low you can take this master volume
and just lower it
because if you bring you know a bunch of
different music clips and it goes to one
after the other but they're all on audio
two
you can just lower them all at once by
this master so if i put this to like
negative
20 some and i raise my voice which is on
audio one
up a little bit i might get something
that's more appropriate for background
music let's just have a listen here with
negative 23 on the audio music and plus
three on on my voice so i'm going to hit
play here somewhere
a little better my voice still sounds
really quiet so you can just like keep
cranking your voice if it's way too
quiet and things like that
so that's the the audio with the master
controls
uh that's generally something you want
to do last i think
so i'm going to go back over to edit
and you know we kind of got those
configured no
that means i won't have to mess with
this audio on each individual track oops
i've got this one negative 12 that might
explain why it was so quiet
put it back to zero
so that you know that might be okay
usually it's like
negative 20 some on the background audio
but your
experience and results may vary
and you can just put effects on your
audio with this kind of stuff i guess
so you just drag it and drop it over it
if you want something i haven't messed
with these a ton
but these can be pretty cool they can
add a lot to your video to to match your
effects or whatever
so it totally it's totally up to your
own creativity but it is there
and once you've made all your cuts and
made all your edits and gotten to the
end and you got your video
how you like how you want and
you know once you're happy with it and
you want to render it
what you do next is you go to deliver
now yes i am skipping over fusion and
i'm skipping over color
those are a little more advanced you're
welcome to play around with them if you
want
but i just don't think they're necessary
for a beginner
you can kind of guess what they do but
anyway you go to deliver
and this is how you render so we've got
our whole
thing here up here at the top left is
what we want to look at mainly
because we have our render settings and
we have an add to render queue button so
once you hit this add a render queue
button
it's going to put it over here on the
right and then you click render
all so you can cue up multiple renders
but generally what i do is if i'm making
the video for youtube
is i just click on youtube here give it
a location
for where i want it to render to
typically for me
this is in this drive called lmas or the
e drive
and then under rendered and then save
and then you change your file name title
right here to what you want it to be
so i might call it mtg draft one or
whatever it is
and just by initially clicking this
youtube 1080p
it sets this stuff pretty well how you
want it
it does have options to upload directly
to youtube i don't use that i manually
upload because
i don't necessarily know what channel i
wanted to go to so you'd have to set up
your account
through here if you want to do this
upload directly i don't use that
but just clicking this getting the auto
settings is super simple
and and puts it in a way that will
definitely work
but you can custom if you know what
you're doing and you're super good at
this stuff and you know what all these
settings are you can just
custom it up i'm just not doing that
okay let me change this again
mtg draft1 is what i would call this for
example
so once everything's fine there i'll
just hit add to render queue
and then when i'm ready to render i just
hit render all now this will take a
little bit of time
it is notably faster than blender if
you're a little familiar with my blender
video editing
you'll find that editing with davinci is
a little bit faster
[Music]
in the long run and it's faster
rendering it's probably because this is
actually made for video editing
blender's still great don't get me wrong
i actually still use a mix of both
for my videos but i tend to use resolve
a lot more
these days because it's just got more
features easier to use features and
stuff like that
so anyway once i hit this render all and
it finishes
what you'll find next is if you go to
this location you'll find your file
your file and you can go review it and
upload it and whatever you want to do
and that's basically it
so i'm just going to hit a quick render
all
and it tells you time remaining it's got
like 18 minutes but i have a lot of
stuff going on like i'm recording with
obs
it would probably go a little faster if
i wasn't doing so much
but that's going to uh yeah you know all
the edits you made
all the work you've done it's going to
push it to one file
like you want it i'm going to go ahead
and stop this because
i don't actually want to finish that and
just for sake of example we'll go into
the file folder go to that drive
go to rendered and there it is right
there
never finished it's uh you know only 40
megabytes
but your finished thing will show up
there and you can do what you want from
it from
there that's to do it for this video let
me know if you guys have any questions
let me know if you want to see any other
special features i can kind of make a
highlight on
any certain features about resolve if
there's a lot of requests like maybe you
want to see more details about editing
cutting
cutting cutting that's not a word um
so you know go back to edit make some
changes
do another draft play around with some
of these effects and stuff
yeah that's basically it oh i hit a
weird audio thing there
all right i just want to say thanks for
watching special shout out to my patrons
for helping me keep going
um if you want to help this channel a
little further
of course just watching the video helps
a lot and hitting like helps a lot for
the algorithm and all that stuff
but also if you want to just further
support
there is a patreon i'll link it down
below
for just a couple bucks you can you can
really help me keep
going with this channel it does help a
lot as it uh
you know it just means it means a lot i
don't know how to handle this patreon
to be honest i want to do special stuff
at some point but for now i think i'm
just going to keep it as a general
support
i'm not going to do a ton i i will
definitely you know if you're a patron
i'll be as quick as i can to answer your
questions
or a lot quicker than the regular
comments at least so
if you want advanced help with some a
project of your own or if you want me to
review something you can
sign up for patreon jump on the discord
go to the ask for review channel
and you know i'll uh i'll review
something of yours
so i'm happy to help out a little bit if
you want to be a patron
but thank you so much everybody for
watching hanging out
keep coding keep working on your
creative stuff
it's all we have in this world sometimes
alright
love you guys peace out see you in the
next episode
matt from code tech and tutorials over
and out